[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي ليال اختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
سباق وتسلح بين روسيا والغرب في اوكرانيا
بالروبوتات وبريطانيا بالدبابات والنيتو
يعدوا باسلحه ثقيله
بشراء المقاتلات والذخائر الخاصه اسرائيل
تواصلوا التجهيز لضربه عسكريه محتمله ضد
منشات ايران النوويه
[موسيقى]
مواعيد كيك
منها
لا تشبه ما حصل
[موسيقى]
البدايه مشاهدينا من اوكرانيا اذا وعد
مزيد من الاسلحه الثقيله في المستقبل
القريب تزامنا مع اعلان لندن دبابات
تشالنجر
لصحيفه يفيد بان المملكه المتحده سترسل
مروحه او سترسل مروحيات اباتشي الى اكياس
ضمن حزمه من المساعدات العسكريه مضيفه
بالوقت ذاتها انا لندن ستقوم بتدريب الجيش
على استخدام الدبابات البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
تشالنجر 2 العمود الفقري لقوه الدبابات في
الجيش البريطاني وهي واحده من اربع دبابات
قتاليه رئيسيه طورتها دول حلف الناتو لخوض
الحروب فهل ستقدر هذه الدبابات على مواجهه
دبابه تي 9 الروسيه احدى افضل دبابات
العالم من حيث الحمايه والتدريع في ساحه
المعركه باوكرانيا مشاهدينا طول دبابات
تشالنجر 2 يتجاوز الاحد 10 مترا ووزنها 62
طنا ونصف دبابه ثقيله الحركه سرعتها تصل
الى 59 كيلو متر في الساعه ويصل مداها الى
450 كلم
اما تي 9t فطولها وطولها هيكلها اقل من
سبعه امتار ووزنها اخف بكثير ويصل الى نحو
48 طنا من ذخائر والافراد قدره عاليه على
المناوره مع السرعه قصوى تصل الى 70 كم في
الساعه بينما يصل مداها الى 500 كلم
تشالنجر 2 مشاهدين الدبابه مصممه لمهاجمه
الدبابات الاخرى وتدميرها تحتوي على دروع
ثقيله ومدفع رئيسي من عيار 22 ملم باثنين
وخمسين قذيفه بالاضافه طبعا لمدفعين اخرين
بمقدار اربعه الاف طلقه فيما المدفع
الرئيسي للدبابه الروسيه فهو من عيار
125 ملم كمان نشاهد هنا اجمالي الطلقات مع
مدفعين اخرين
2340 طلقه ومجهز بصواريخ موجهه مداها خمسه
كيلومترات تتميز تي 9t بالنظام قليل
التحكم في اطلاق النار هنا الدبابه
باستطاعتها البحث عن الاهداف وتعقب هذه
الاهداف في وضع الثبات او الحركه ليلا او
نهارا ايا كانت الظروف الجويه بالعوده
مشاهدينا الى تشالنجر هي مصممه لعبور
التضاريس المفتوحه
وتمثلها بذلك الدبابه الروسيه ذات القدره
العاليه على اجتياز الموانع الطبيعيه
[موسيقى]
وادي مقابل هذا الدعم الغربيه
كانظام امان لقاعده
الفضائيه ما يوفر التحكم في محيطها الامني
اما الان فسيكون هناك العديد من الروبوتات
ماركر في منطقه التماس في دوباس تحديدا
وعن مواصفات هذا المقاتل الواعد او
الروبوت الذكي مشاهدينا فهو عباره عن مجمع
عن تقلي الي بوزن نحو ثلاثه اطنان يمكن ان
يزود يزود باسلحه مختلفه بما في ذلك انظمه
الدفاع الجوي القصيره المدويه ويتميز
الروبوت بخفه الحركه حيث يستطيع التعرف
على الاهداف لا سيما الجويه منها اعتمادا
على تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي كما
يستطيع ايضا تحديد اهداف العدو من مسافه
15 كلم وكذلك تحديد اولوياته بحيث يستهدف
مهاجمي العدو في منطقه الهزيمه بنيرانه
الخاصه ويتمتع مشاهدينا ماركر برؤيه تقنيه
ونظام تحكم الي ويعمل بشكل مستقل في ظروف
الحرب السبرانيه والهجمات باستخدام موجات
الراديو ويؤدي مهامه القتاليه بشكل مستقل
وقد تم اختبار ماركر اثناء اداء مهام خفر
منشات البنيه تحتيها الفضائيه وخفر
المطارات حيث استخدم لاكتشاف كل ما يحاول
اختراق واشتياز المناطق المراد حراستها
والتعرف عليهم والحيلوله دون وقوع هجمات
ارهابيه ومكافحه طبعا المسيره
[موسيقى]
منك يافا ينضم الينا حذيفه عادل مراسل
العربيه حذيفه يعني عندما نتحدث عن
تشالنجر 2 السلاح الرئيسي يعني بالقوات او
العتاد البريطاني كيف يمكن ان يغير على
الارض وماذا عن عمليات التسليم وكل
التفاصيل
نعم مساء الخير ليال اول نرصد احتفال كبير
في تصريح ستورمبرج حول نقل اسلحه ثقيله
وتسليم اسلحه ثقيله للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه في الاعلام الاوكراني في قنوات
التليجرام الاوكرانيه في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي هنالك احتفال كبير بهذا التصريح
وطبعا سبقه عدد من التصريحات خاصه من بعض
المسؤولين طبعا الرئيس الفرنسي في حديث مع
الرئيس الاوكراني ايمانويل مع الرئيس
الامريكي
على نقل اي ام اكس 10 وهي الدبابه
الفرنسيه وهذا الامر ايضا لقي ترحيب كبير
من او من همم الجانب الاوكراني وخاصه شعب
بنقل مثل هذه الاسلحه همم عقبه ذلك مباشره
اعلنت بريطانيا عن تسليم تشارلينجر الى
الجيش الاخرى هذا الامر قد ياخذ اسابيع
كما افاده وزير الدفاع عن اوكراني همم
يعني في اقصى حد قد يكون شهرين كما افاد
همم في بدايه طبعا ستكون هنالك عمليات
تدريب عمليات التدريب ليال لا تكون داخل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه لانه يكون هنالك عمليه
استهداف مباشره من قبل الاتحاد الروسي ل-
اا ميادين التدريب لذلك ينتقل الجنود الى
اراضي الاتحاد الاوروبي هناك في امم يعني
هنالك معسكرات معينه وهنالك مناطق معينه
يتم فيها التدريب مثل تشالنجر طبعا سوف
ينتقلون الى همم بريطانيا للتدريب على هذه
الدبابه ثم بعد ذلك طبعا ستكون هنالك
مجموعه صغيره بعد ذلك هذه المجموعه ستنقل
الخبرات الى الجيش الاوكراني والى الجنود
داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه هذا بالضبط ما
حدث مع بطاريات باتريوت الامريكيه والان
يعني في هذا الاسبوع قد سافر بالفعل
مجموعه من الجنود الاخرانيين للتدريب في
واشنطن على هذه همم النظام همم الصواريخ
باتريوت وكذلك ايضا الان هنالك همم يعني
مناقشات تدور حول ليبرتو الدبابه
الالمانيه الان برلين تدرس فعليا تسليم
برده الى الجيش الاوكراني سوف يتم مناقشه
هذا الامر خلال الاسبوع القادم سيتخذ
القرار قبل 20 من يناير وهو موعد اجتماع
همم يعني المجلس او همم مجموعه وزراء
الدفاع الاتحاد
اوكرانيا وهذا هو المجلس الاستشاري لل
الجيش الاوكراني من الشركاء طبعا همم يعني
قبل ذلك سيتم اتخاذ القرار من قبل همم
برلين وبعد ذلك سيتم اختار الجانب
الاوكراني بتسليم هذه الدبابات من عدمه
ولكن الجميع يتوقع انه سوف يتم نقل هذه
الدبابات نحن نتحدث عن مرحله جديده من
التسليح الغربي همم هذه المرحله كيف يمكن
ان تغير بمجريات الحرب على الارض خصوصا
يعني هل ممكن ان توازي التسليح الروسي
الذي انتقل الى مرحله الروبوتات ال- الان
نعم اعتمادا طبعا على اخر تصريح لي او
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني الكثيرزنكو الذي
قال اننا حصلنا من حلف الناتو على ما
نريده ونحن فعليا نعم لم ننضم الى حلف
الناتو بشكل رسمي ولكن انا حصلنا على ما
نريده من الحلفانته وهو عمليه التسليح
بالاسلحه الثقيله طبعا هذا سيغير كثيرا
على ارض المعركه في الجوانب المختلفه خاصه
طبعا ااه الدبابات والمدرعات طبعا ايضا
الان اتمنى الموافقه على تسليم اوكرانيا
همم المدرعات الناقله للجنود الجيش
الاوكراني يعاني في عمليه نقل الجنود لانه
يستخدم يعني سيارات عاديه لنقل الجنود
وهديه باستهدافها بسهوله ولكن المدرعات هي
تستطيع ان تسير في الطرق طبعا ارض المعركه
هناك ال- ال- الطرق صعبه جدا على السيارات
العاديه
والجانب الفرنسي ايضا وافق على نقل
المدرعات ناقله الجنود امريكا طبعا همم
ايضا برادلي وافقت على نقل برادلي الى
الاراضي الاوكرانيا كل ذلك وكل هذه
الاسلحه سوف تغير في ارض المعركه لو
لاحظتي في عمليات الضربات الجويه
والصاروخيه هنالك عدد كبير من الصواريخ
يتم تدميرها في الجو هذا طبعا ينسب الفضل
الى مجموعه انظمه الدفاع الجوي التي تم
تسليمها بالفعل الى الجانب الاوكراني كذلك
في التقدم البري هذه الدبابات سوف تشكل
فارقا كبيرا الان عين اوكرانيا بعد ان تم
الموافقه على تسليم الدبابات وبعد عن حصلت
على بعض من انظمه الدفاع الجوي الان عين
اوكراني على الطائرات المقاتله الحربيه
وهذا الان ما يطالب به المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين وطبعا نتوقع بعد ذلك انهم سوف
يكونون همم يعني سيضعون عينهم على اسلحه
هجوميه طبعا انهم يقولون انهم اذا حدث اذا
حصلوا على الاسلحه هل الهجوميه يستطيعون
تحرير اراضيهم في خلال اسابيع شكرا لك
حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه حدثنا كاس
نشرت هيئه حرس الحدود الاوكرانيه تسجيلا
للوحده تقوم بقصف قوات الروسيه بالقرب من
منطقه سوليدر وحسب البيان الذي نشرته
الهيئه تم تدمير وحده روسيه كان افرادها
مختبئين في فنادق بقصف بطائرات بدون طيار
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قال المتحدث باسمي وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان القوات الروسيه حقق التقدما في مناطق
بشمال باخ موت خلال القتال يوم امس حيث
تمكنت من تدمير اكثر من 80 جنديا اوكرانيا
ودبابتين او قتل اكثر من 80 جنديا
اوكرانيا وتدمير دبابتين وثلاث عربات
قتاليه مدرعه وثلاث سيارات في يوم واحد
نظيف
بالتعاون مع وحده من القوات المحموله جوا
ودعم من طيران الجيش والقوات الصواريخ
والمدفعيه للمنطقه العسكريه الجنوبيه حققت
نجاحا في اتجاه الضواحي الشماليه في
باخموت خلال القتال تم القضاء على اكثر من
80 جنديا اوكرانيا ودبابتين وثلاثين
مركبات قتاليه مدرعه وثلاث سيارات في يوم
واحد
خاص قتلوا في ما اصيب ثلاثه همم 13 اخرين
جراء انفجار ذخيره بمنطقه بالجولدن
الروسيه وسائل اعلام الروسيه اوضحت ان
الانفجار وقع بعد ما اساء جنديه التعامل
مع قنبله يدويه في مركز ثقافي محالي في
المنطقه ثم تحويله سابقا الى مستودعا
للخير
[موسيقى]
تزامنا مع وضع رئيس النظام السوري بشار
الاسد شروطا لاعاده التطبيع العلاقات مع
انقره ابرز هذه الشروط انهاء الوجود
التركي على الاراضي السوريه عهدت مساله
تعديل بنود اتفاقيه اضنه بين كل من انقره
ودمشق للواجهه من جديد وهو مطلب تركي
بالطبع الذي يدعو الى توسيع على اتفاقيه
لتشمل حق الدخول مسافه 30 كلم بدلا من
خمسه وفقا لنسخه عام 1990
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من اسطنبول زيدان
مراسل العربيه زيدان يعني تعديل الملحق
الرابع تحديدا بهذه الاتفاقيه والذي كنا
نتحدث عن مضمون بموضوع المنطقه الامنه امم
الحديث عنه وتاجيل ليس بالجديد عند كل ما
نتحدث عن مفاوضات بين النظام وتركيا تعاد
هذه الاتفاقيه من جديد اليوم هل يعني
العامل الاساسي هي هذه النقطه وما هي
تحفظات انقره على التسويف دمشق بهذا
الموضوع
نعم حقيقه ان هذه الموضوع تعديل اتفاقيه
اضنه وكما ذكرت اكثر من مره على شاشه
العربيه منذ بدا الحديث عن ااا عوده
العلاقات ما بين انقره ودمشق عن هذا
الموضوع وهذه القضيه هي القضيه الاولى على
الطاوله من قبل الاتراك امام محاورهم من
النظام السوري لذلك تعتقد ان قرانا مسار
تعديل هذه الاتفاقيه هو مسار طويل لكن بغض
النظر عن هذا المسار الطويل كانت انقره
تريد همم لقاءا صوريا كما ان صحت هذه
التسميه ما بين همم الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان وهو بين رئيس النظام السوري بشار
الاسد للاستفاده من هذا اللقاء في الحملات
الانتخابيه لحزب العداله والتنميه قبل
الانتخابات القادمه لكن بعيدا عن هذه
النقطه وموضوع العرقله او تعثر همم لقاءات
التي كان من المنتظر ان تكون سريعه وان
يكون لقاء الوزراء الخارجيه همم وزير
الخارج التركي مع نظيره همم السوري وايضا
الروسي كان الحديث من قبل الاعلام التركي
ومن الاوساط التركيه ان هذا لقاء يجب ان
يكون قبل توجه وزير الخارجيه التركي في
السابعه عشر من يناير اي بعد يومين فقط
الى واشنطن لكن على ما يبدو ان هذا اللقاء
تاجل هناك اعتقاد في الاوساط التركيه ان
العامل الايراني ظهر مؤخرا وفي الايام
القليله الماضيه همم في هذا المسار مسار
التدقيق ما بين دمشق وانقره الجانب التركي
يعتقد ان طهران تريد جر هذا المسار الى
مسار استانا التي الذي يضم ايضا اضافه الى
روسيا كلا من تركيا
وايران لذلك تعتقد انقره او هناك اعتقاد
في انقر بان العامل الايراني ربما سيكون
معرقلا لهذه لهذا المسار ما لم يتم ادراج
طهران في هذا الموضوع
من المعلوم انه هناك اليوم تضارب مصالح
بين كل من الايراني والروسي بهذا الملف
همم بسوريا
بوسي كان اكد قد يعني دفش اكثر من مره حول
نحو ايجاد حل بهذا التعديل هل ممكن ان
يضغط اكثر على الجانبين ام ان العامل
الايراني سيكون المعرق الاساسي ولن يكن
هناك تعديل
صراحه ان يكون للجانب الروسي همم دور اكبر
وفعال اكثر في الدفع والضغط على دمشق اكثر
للذهاب اولا الى اللقاء وزراء الخارجيه
ومن ثم همم موضوع همم
ثم الموضوع لقاء رؤساء لاسيه مع ان همم
انقر من خلال مباحثات المرتقبه لوزير
الخارجيه في الولايات المتحده ربما يكون
هناك ورقه اخرى او ربما يكون هناك كلام
اخر من واشنطن همم على الطاوله ربما انقر
تستفيد من هذا الموضوع ما زالت حتى الان
اجانب التركي يعمل همم ويريد من الجانب
الروسي اكثر همم في هذا المسار لا شك ان
انقر ستكون مرتاحه اكثر في التعامل مع
موسكو همم بشكل منفرج اكثر من التعامل مع
طهران وموسكو على الطاوله في مسار استانا
لذلك تفضل انقره وهذا طبعا كلام غير رسم
لكن ما همم يتم رصده من خلال وسائل
الاعلام ومن خلال ما همم
معناها من بعض المطلعين على هذا الموضوع
تفضل انقره البقاء او ابقاء هذا المسار ما
بين موسكو وانقر ودمشق فقط دون وجود عام
اخر تعلم انقره ايضا انه في حال تقدمت
المفاوضات واستمرت يجب ان يكون قوى فاعل
لاسيمه الولايات المتحده للمساعده على
تطبيق القرار 22.54 22 54 لكن حتى وصول
الوصول الى تلك المرحله تفضل انقره
التفاهم مع موسكو فقط شكرا لك زيدان على
هذه الرساله من اسطنبول
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وقتلها بعد قليل
بعد تلقيها ضمانات بعدم التعرض من طالبان
منظمه انقذوا الاطفال تستانف عملها في
افغانستان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد افاد مصدر عسكري
اسرائيلي بان خطه الهجوم المستقله على
منشات ايران النوويه ليست جاهزه تماما
واضح المصدر انه سيتم
ستتم هجمات او مهاجمه منشات ايران نوويه
في اي وقت في حاله اصدار المستوى السياسي
امرا بذلك واشار المصدر الى ان اسرائيل
تواصل التجهيز لضربه عسكريه لايران عبر
شراء مقاتلات وذخائر خاصه واكد المصدر ان
الغارات الاسرائيليه على سوريا تعطل تواضع
ايران العسكري هناك
[موسيقى]
مع دخولي هالشهر الخامس احتجاجاته ايران
مستمره لبل تغذيها يوميا اسباب جديده من
مقدمتها الاعدامات ففي العاصمه طهران شهدت
مناطق مختلفه هتافات مناهضه للنظام واطلاق
سفرات الثوره كحتجاج رمزي كما شكلت مساكن
الطلاب في العاصمه مسرحا للاحتجاجات
الليليه التي نددت باعدام رفاقهم مؤكده
البقاء حتى النهايه ياتي ذلك مشاهدينا
بالتزامن مع حكم بالاعدام اصدره القضاء
الايراني بحق ثلاثه مواطنين هم صالح
مراهمي ومشيد يعقوب وسعيد كاظم وفي القضيه
نفسها المعروفه باسم بيت اصفهان حكم على
لاعب كره القدم امير نصري نصر اذاني
بالسجن سته وعشرين عاما اما التهما فهي
العضويه في التجمعات غير القانونيه بهدف
الاخلالي بامن البلاد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نعم
ذكرت الاذاعه الرسميه الايرانيه ان عشرات
الالف من الايرانيين تركوا بدون غاز
لتدفئه منازلهم يوم امس مع انتشار الطقس
البارد بشكل غير عادي في جميع انحاء
البلاد وفقا لموقع انترناشونال نيوز
الايراني فقد اشار حاكم مقاطعه خرسانه
الشماليه الشرقيه الى انقطاع شحنات الغاز
عن تسعينا الف مستخدم على الاقل كما تعطلت
الامدادات عن ما لا يقل عن اربع مقاطعات
شماليه اخرى وعدت مناطق بالقرب من الحدود
الشرقيه للبلاد فيما امرت السلطات باغلاق
المدارس والمكاتب التي تديرها الدوله
داعيه للمواطنين الى تجنب السفر الى مدينه
مشهد
من موازات سخرت صحف لبنانيه من عرض متجدد
لوزير الخارجيه الايراني بمساعده لبنان في
مجال الطاقه واضافات انه كا سابقاته من
المرات لا ينطوي الا على رسائل فالمساعدات
الاقتصاديه الايرانيه الموعوده لم يتلقاها
لبنان ابدا وبحسب صحف محليه فان ايران غير
قادره على مساعده نفسها لتنهال على لبنان
بعروض تامين الخيول والمحروقات لتشغيل
معامل الانتاج الطاقه والموجوده واستحداث
معمالين اضافيين حيث تعاني ايران مشاهدينا
حاليا من استمرار ازمه الطاقه وتحديدا
القاسم اكثر من نصف المدن باتت في حاله
شبه اغلاق بينها مازن تران واصفهان
وقزويان والبس دوائر حكوميه ومدارس
وجامعات مغلقه تماما وايضا المخابز بعضها
توقف عن العمل بسبب نقص الغاز كما اكدت
تقارير متداوله انقطاع الغاز في المنازل
وانقطاع الكهرباء واغلاق محطات الوقود
لنقص في ماده البنزين تحديدا
[موسيقى]
سويت شوارع دينك
بوضع قيود توريد النفط الايراني الرخيص
الى سوريا الامر الذي تسبب في ازمه حيث
قام الطهران بمضاعفه السعر الذي تدفعه
دمشق مقابل النفط الخام مما ادى الى نقص
الوقود في سوريا تزامنا معا انهيار
اقتصادها وحسب وسائل الاعلام سوريا تسبب
النقص في طوابير انتظار امام محطات الوقود
ايران رفعت السعر من 30 الى اكثر من 70
دولار للبرميل الامريكي
ينضم الينا من باريس الدكتور منذر ما خوص
الباحث في الاقتصاد السياسي والعلاقات
الدوليه دكتور منذر على ما يبدو اليوم
هناك شقين
بالتغيير الايراني مع النظام بموضوع توريد
الغاز والنفط الاول هو الشق السياسي
والثاني هو الشق الاقتصادي داخل طهران
بالشوق السياسي اليوم هناك انزعاج ايراني
من التقارب
التركي ال همم مع النظام الاسد وطبعا
الدور الروسي المتنامي اكثر بهذا الملف
لاي مدى هذا الشق يلعب اليوم دور بما
بالقرار الذي اتخذته ايران
نعم هذا الموضوع يلعب دورا لا باس به في
هذا التحول في الموقف الايراني الذي كان
هناك منذ اسابيع وربما اشهر مقدماتي مثل
هذا الموقف الان اصبح هذا موقف موثق ومؤكد
بالاضافه الى السبب المهم الذي تفضلت به
هناك حقيقه اسباب اخرى لانه يجب ان ناخذ
بعين الاعتبار انه في الظروف الحاليه
الاقتصاد الدولي عندما نجد ان هناك ازمه
في نقص الوقود على الصعيد العالمي برمته
خاصه على خلفيه الحرب الموجوده حاليا في
اوكرانيا على الرغم ان ايران هناك عقوبات
تمنع ايران بما بهم امور كثيره بما في ذلك
تصدير النفط لكن الان ضمن هذه الازمه ضمن
النقص الحاد في النقود على الصعيد الدولي
اصبحت لدى اراف اخرى اهم من السابق في
تصدير الوقود والنفط على وجه التحديد
ده الموضوع مهم لانه يعني على ان ايران
لها مصلحه في بيع
نفطها باسعار السوق التي هي مرتفعه كما
نعرف خطا ضمن الازمه الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه التي تعرف ايران على الصعيد
الاخر هناك موضوع الحرب وانعكاساتها على
هذا الموضوع بما في ذلك ايضا موضوع
العلاقات والتنافس بين روسيا وايران على
النفوس في سوريا همم فيما يتعلق بالنظام
السوري الوضع الحالي في الحرب الاوكرانيات
يتيح لايران فرصه للاستفاده من
الانشغال الروسي الكبير في هذه الحرب ومن
اجل محاوله تحقيق مكاسب اكثر في الضغط على
النظام وتحقيق ايضا نفوذ اكثر من مكان في
السابق هذه العوامل ادت الى اتخاذ مثل هذا
القرار هذه الموضوع الداخلي يعني كما
تبعنا قبل قليل الازمه همم الوقود موجوده
بالداخل الايراني من المعلوم ان ارجعها
الشماليه من ايران تستورد الغاز من
تركمانستان وايضا بالتقاري يتركمستان
بالفتره الماضيه لديها ازمه داخليه
وتستعمل اا مخزونه للاستهلاك الدخل
وبالتالي هناك نقص هناك نقص موجود فعلا
ولكن النقطه الاساسيه ان ايران لديها
مشكله موثوقيه واستمراريه بموضوع التصدير
امم يعني هذه النقطه بموازات النقطه
الاخرى والتي تقول بان لا شيء همم ببلاش
صح التعبير مع النظام الايراني الى اي مدى
لعب دور
بتشفيف مصادر النفط لان النظام الاسد
نعم نحن نعرف تماما مره اخرى ضمن الظروف
الدوليه الراهنه ظروف عظمه الطاقه التي
اتاحت لايران فرص جديده ان تبيع نفطها
باسعار اكبر بكثير من مكانه في السابق بما
يتماشى مع الاسعار الدوليه الان ووجود فرص
افضل لايران الان من اجل تصدير نفطها لكن
هذا لا يغني في شيء عن ان ايران بالاصل
لديها كما تفضلت ازمات في الغاز على الرام
ان ايران بالمناسبه بشكل عام طبعا الغاز
التي تستورده من ترك البستان ولي اطراف
بعيده او لمناطق بعيده عن وسط ايران ايران
تملك احتياطي من الغاز كما نعرف في
خليج العربي همم وهي واحده من اكبر
الاحتياطات في العالم ترتيب ايران اليوم
هو الثاني بعد روسيا بالمناسبه وهي مع قطر
يتقاسمان هذا الحقل العملاق الذي اسمه حقل
الشمال في الخليج العربي لكن ما يبدو ان
ان غاز هذا لا تملك كل الان ايران اي فراس
لتصديرها الخارج لان هذا يحتاج اما الى
انابيب غاز او الى تميعه وتحويله الى غاز
سائل لديها دائما مشاكل لوجسيه بموضوع
بموضوع التشغيل وموضوع اداره الموارد يعني
النظام لديه دائما بكل نماذجيه بالدول
المنطقه موضوع اداره مشكله باداره الموارد
هذا صحيح تماما خاصه على خلفيه ما يحدث
الان في ايران الانتفاضات التي بدات ولم
تتوقف وليس هناك افق على الاطلاق ان تتوقف
هذا يخلق ضغوط اجتماعيه واقتصاديه بالاصل
نحن نعرف كما قلت ايه وكما نعرف جميعا على
هناك ازمات اقتصاديه غير محدوده في ايران
كما هناك في سوريا لدى النظام السوري ايضا
ازمات اقتصاديه غير مسبوقه وفي مقدمتها
ازمه الوقود على الرغم ان سوريا كما نعرف
احتياط صحيح متواضع ولكنه غير موجود تحت
السلطه النظام السوري هذا ايضا يجعل على
انه هناك ازمه كبيره جدا وهي تعني الطرفين
في ان واحد ولكن الايرانيون يحاولون الان
الاستفاده من الظروف الراهنه فيما يتعلق
به مساله
السيطره على النفوس كان طفل
دكتور منذر مع خاص ايه الباحث في الاقتصاد
السياسي والعلاقات الدوليه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت منظمه انقذوا الاطفال انها ستستانف
عملها في افغانستان وذلك بعد وعود من
طالبان بعدم التعرض لموظفاتها وقالت
المنظمه في بيان انها تلقى تاكدات من
طالبان لان موظفاتها يمكنهن العمل دون
عوائق مشيره الى ان المجالات التي ستستاني
في العمل فيها تشمل ومجالات الصحه
والتغذيه والخدمات التعليميه
[موسيقى]
افادت صحيفه وصجون الامريكيه بان رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع السوداني دافع
عن وجود القوات
الامريكيه جدول زمني الانسحابها وبحسب
الصحيفه فان السوداني اشار الى ان الحاجه
للقوات الاجنبيه لا تزال قائمه وان القضاء
على تنظيم داعش يحتاج الى المزيد من الوقت
في اشاره الى فرق القوات الامريكيه
التي تدرب وتساعد الوحدات العراقيه في
مكافحه التنظيم بحسب الصحيح
[موسيقى]
قضيه وثائق الرئيس الامريكي جروبايدن ربما
تكون اسوا من حاله سلفيت ترامب وفقا لوصف
صحيفه التلغراف التي ترى ان وثائق بايدين
عثر عليها بينما هو في منصبه كرئيس بينما
ترامب عثر عليها بعد مغادر
وترى صحيفه ان الوضع خطير للغايه بالنسبه
لكل الرجلين حيث يمكن ان يكون كل منهما
قدر ارتكب جرائم بموجب قانون السجلات
الرئاسيه وقانون التجسس اذا كان قد تصرف
باهمال جسيم وفقا للثلاجراف
تشبه عابر تحمله وتحقيقات الجاريه بشان
الوثائق السريه المكتشفه بحوزه بايدين
وتلك التي لا تزال جاريه بحق السلفه وفق
صحيفه بوليتكو التي تخالف التلغراف في
قراءه هذه القضيه فصحيفه الامريكيه شبهت
الموقف اكثر بما حدث مع وزيره الخارجيه
السابقه هيلاري كلينتون احتفاظ غير مقصود
بمواد سريه ببريدها الالكتروني الخاص
واضافت الصحيفه ان ترامب يخضع للتحقيق
بسبب الاحتفاظ المتعمد بسجلات سريه وتجاهل
طلبات اعادتها لوزاره العدل رغم الطلبات
المتكرره من مسؤولين حيدر في اعاقه سير
العداله قد تكون تهمه بحد ذاتها حتى ولو
قرر مسؤوله وزاره العدل العام عدم
توجيهاتهامات تتعلق بسجلات السريه
نتسلم الوفاق مباشره رغم عدم وجود خطابات
لتسليمها او مذكرات استدعاء او اوامر
تفتيش ورغم ان تحقيق بايدن لا يزال في
مرحله مبكره رجحت بوليتكو ان لا ينطبق اي
من القوانين التي يخضع ترامب لتحقيق
بسببها وبسبب انتهاكها على سلوك بيضا
موضحه او مضيحه ان الاهمال الجسيم قد يكون
التهمه اي مخالفه القانون الذي يعاقب على
فقدان او حذف معلومات الدفاع الوطني وهو
ما بنى عليه مدير مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه السابق تحقيقه بشان البريد
الالكتروني الخاص بهلال عليك الانترنت
[موسيقى]
التصريح الامنيه لتفتيش منزل الرئيس
الامريكي بات موجوده والوثائق السريه
المكتشفه الى خمس صفحات اضافيه من المواد
السريه اعلن البيت الابيض العثور عليها في
مقر اقامه هذه الصفحات تعود كذلك الى عهد
اوباما اي حين كان بيضا نائبا للرئيس وعثر
عليها او عثر عليها محامي البيت الابيض
خلال زيارته للمنزل
واحدا بعلامه سريه في غرفه مجاوره لمراد
السيارات لكنهم توقفوا عن التفتيش لعدم
امتلاهم تصريحا امنيا وفقا صحيفه واشنطن
بوست وتضاف هذه الوثائق الى اخرى مماثله
بسريتها عثر عليها في موقعين احد هدينا
الموقعين المنزل المذكور والاخر هو مكتب
السابق في مركز ابحاث مباشره ليرتفع عدد
المواد الحكوميه المكتشفه اه ده سبايدر
الى 16 وثيقه حتى اللحظه واصبحت موضوع
تحقيقات بوزاره العدل وكذلك سلاحا لزعيم
كرئيس مجلس النواب الذي حظ الكونغرس على
التحقيق يعني ذلك طبعا مشاهدينا وسط
استبعاد اي تعرض جنائي للرئيس في القضيه
فالمعالجه غير الصحيحه للسجلات وتخزين هذه
السجلات كان نتيجه لخطا من قبل مساعده
الذين افرغوا مكتبه
من مساعديه مبديا اسفه العميق احتماليه
التشبيه خاطئ قد يجريه الجمهوريون بين
افعال بيضا وتصرفات التراب
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا مشاهدينا من واشنط ناديه
البلبيسي مراسيلك العربيه ناديه يعني
الصحف الغربيه حول المسار القانوني لقضيه
الرئيس ما الاصح منها ومن يعني المتوقع
قانونيا وادي السوريا لهذه القضيه
اهلا بك يا ليال في الواقع لا يوجد وجهه
نظر قانونيه ثابته بمعنى هناك انقسام بين
المحامين وحسب طبعا انتمائي من الحزبه بعض
المحامين المحافظين يقولون بان الرئيس
بايدن يتعرض لخطر اكبر قانوني طبعا
بالمقارنه مع الرئيس ترامب لانه ترامب قام
بنزع السريه عن هذا الوثائق قبل ان يحتفظ
بها في منتجع في
طبعا هذه نقطه خلافيه بالنهايه يعني هل
يستطيع الرئيس هل صلاحيات الرئيس او من
صلاحيات الكونجرس بعد فقرات الدستور تعطيه
بعد الصلاحيات لكنها محدوده وبالتالي هناك
انقسام لا احد ان يستطيع ان يجزم هل
بالفعل سيتعرض لمحاسبه قانونيه اجراميه او
لا لكن اليوم مثلا في البيت الابيض هذه
انه على المال لانه كما تعرفين اجازه في
دلاليه اليوم غدا الرئيس بعد الموجود في
اتلانتس الاحياء ذكرى ماتن لوثر كينج لكن
هناك عاصفه سياسيه تنتظر عندما يعود ويبدا
اليوم همم طبعا الرسمي يوم الثلاثاء لماذا
لانه بالفعل هناك اتهامات للبيت الابيض
بعدم الشفافيه الرئيس يقول بانه لا يعرف
ما هي هذه الاوراق وما فيها وكما ذكرت قبل
قليل قال بانه ربما خطا احمق من
المستشارين المحامين الذين كانوا يعملوا
معه بانهم يحتفظوا بهد الوثائق دون ان
يعلموه عاده عند ذلك هناك بعض المقارنات
مع الرئيس ترامب ومع هيركلينتون تحدثنا
عليها عنها خلال ايام وكما ذكرت بالتحديد
بان ترامب يواجه اتهامات بعرقله مجرى
العداله بانه لم يسلم هذه الاوراق عددها
الوثائق 20 بالمقابل 3 احتفظ بها ترامب
الى اخره لكن بغض النظر اذا كان هناك
قانونيه تجارب الرئيس او لا هناك ايضا
محاسبه وموسائله وشيكه من مجلس النواب
الذي يفتح كل الصفحات للرئيس علاقه ابنه
باوكرانيا وبالصين الانسحاب الفوضى من
افغانستان والا قدم لهم هذا الملف على
ورقه على طبق من ذهب ماذا سيفعل النواب
طبعا في الكونجرس هذا هو السؤال الاكبر هل
سيتم المتابعه والمحاسبه حتى الترشح
للانتخابات القادمه 20 24 هذا هو المتوقع
وهذه ايضا النقطه المهمه هل سيترشح الرئيس
بايرن في ظل هذا الوحل السياسي اذا اردتي
بين قوسين الذي يبدو بانه سيعلق به حتى
موعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه
شكرا لك ناديه البلبيسي مراسله العربيه
على هذه الرساله من واشنطن
مشاهدينا 9 مستمره فيها بعد قليل
انتشال ثمانيه او ثمان 68 جثه من موقع
تحطم طائره ركاب في نيبال والبحث جاري عن
اربعه مفقودين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت السلطات النيباليه
مصرع جميع من كانوا على متن الطائره
المنكوبه في مدينه بخارى سياحيه وعددهم
اثنان وسبعون شخصا وقالت هيئه الطيران
المدني النيباليه في بيان ان الطائره كانت
ذات محركان من طراز اي تي ار 7 2 التي
تدورها شركه
الجويه بدوله اوضح رئيس الوزراء النيبالي
ان الطائره كانت في طريقها من العاصمه الى
مدينه بخارى وسط النيبال فيما لم يتضح بعد
سبب تحكم الطائره يذكر ان مدينه بخار تعد
مثلا شهيرا للترحال لمسافات طويله في جبال
الهملايا كان مطار بخار الدولي بدا عمليته
منذ اسبوعين فقط وبحسب قاعده بيانات سلامه
الطيران التابعه لمؤسسه سلامه الطيران فقد
وقع اسنانه واربعون حادثا مميثا مماثله في
نيبال منذ العام 1946
[موسيقى]
اعوذ بالله
هذا واظهرت المعلومات عن الطائره التي
تحطمت فينابال كانت من طراز اي تي ار 7 2
وهي طائره صغيره الحجم تستخدمها العديد من
خطوط الطيران حول العالم في الرحلات
القصيره هذه مشاهدينا بعض المعلومات عنها
فلتبعها
طائره اي تي ار 72 المنكوبه
طائره تجاريه تصنعها شركه اي تي ار
الفرنسيه الايطاليه
دخلت الخدمه لاول مره سنه 1988
الى 78
[موسيقى]
تعرضت هذه طائره ل 12 حديثه تتحطم نموذج
بدايه استخدامها
تسببت هذه الحوادث في وفاه حوالي 466 شخصا
تستخدمها العديد من الخطوط حول العالم في
الرحلات القصيده
ليست من جديده على نابل فهي تشهد حوادث
طيران بشعه كل عامين تقريبا تنتهي بكوارث
واعداد ضحايا كبيره
الكارثه التي اسفرت عن مقتل العشرات بعد
تحطم طائره ركاب في نيبال ليست الاولى من
نوعها
على مدى عوامل كثيره حوادث تحطم الطائرات
في نيبال ووقعت 42 حديثه منذ عام
1946 في العام 1992 177 راكبا على متن
طائره باكستانيه فقد حياتهم في العام 2012
بالعامي 2016 تحطم طائره توين اوتر ومقتل
جميع ركبها وعددهم 23
في العام 2018 مقتل 49 شخصا بعد تقدم
طائره ميغاليه امريكيه
ليس ببعيدا عن النيبال والكوارث في
الفلبين تحديدا لقيا 27 شخصا مصرعهم وفقد
ثلاثه فقد ثلاثه جراء العواصف التي اصابت
البلاد حيث يتواصل هطول الامطار الغزيره
في هذا البلد المعرض لكوارث طبيعيه هذا
وقال مكتب الدفاع المدني في تقرير احد ان
العواصف المتتاليه منذ الثالث من يناير
بحياه 27 شخصا اذا شرفت مياه الفيضانات
منازل ودمرت طرقا واغرقت المحاصيل كما ادت
الى جرح 11 شخصا وفقد ثلاثه اخرين
[موسيقى]
اكد رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان دعم القوات المسلحه لكل
خطوه تقود الى الانتقال الديمقراطيه وجدد
البرهان ترحيبه بالاتفاق الايطالي معربا
عن اعتقاده بانه سيوحد شمل السودانيه
القوات المسلحه
منانه انه نشوف القوات المسلحه بعيده من
السياسه بنانا نشور القوات المسلحه قوات
محترفه ما عندها علاقه بالتنظيمات
السياسيه ما فيها اخوان ولا فيها يا
ساريين ولا فيها يمين ووقف مسلحه سودانيه
حق السودان هي صمام امان هذا السودان عشان
كده بنقول نحن والله
ماشيين في التوافق الحصل نحن متوقع انه ما
تم توقيعه من اتفاق ايطالي يخرج هذه
البلاد من وحدته ويوحد شملنا ويحينا عشان
نبني هذا البلد اهلنا
طويله وبلدنا معنا سنين طويله ما عندنا اي
طريقه غير اننا نلبي نداء الشعب السوداني
هذا ورفض رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان انتقادا المؤسسه العسكريه
مطالبا السياسيين بعدم التحدث في شؤون
الجيش والانشغال بترتيب صفوفهم
[موسيقى]
الكلام ده نحن بنقوله ونحن نموت قدامك
الكلام ده دي مسؤوليتنا انه نحافظ على
الجيش ده بوحدته متماسك قوي يحمي هذا
البلد ويحمي الدوله السودانيه وبنقول
لاخواننا السياسيين بتتكلموا ان شاء الله
الجيش احسن تشوفوا شغلكم
خلونا احنا قادرين باننا ناخذنا الجيش ده
في الطريق الصحيح
وما زلنا في السودان مشاهدينا ازدادت
محكمه زوجه الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير
وداد بابكر بتهمه الثراء الحرام بعدما ظلت
تست المراتب زوجها الاول بعد زواجها
الثاني باحدى عشر عاما وحكمت المحكمه
بمصادره العقارات والاموال والاحجار
الكريمه التي تملكها وداد بابكر بالاضافه
الى مصادره حسابين بنكين ودفع غرامات 100
مليون جنيه سوداني
[موسيقى]
اعلنت سلطات الصوماليه عشان ما سمته باكبر
عمليه عسكريه لاستهداف حركه الشباب
المرتبطه بتنظيم القاعده منذ اكثر من 10
سنوات هذا وداعت الحكومه الصوماليه
المواطنين للوقوف في وجه الارهابيين
المرتبطين بتنظيم القاعده في السياق شدد
السفير الامريكي بالنجاح الذي حققته
القوات قوات الامن الصوماليه في معركتها
التاريخيه لتحرير المجتمعات الصوماليه
التي تعاني في ظل تواجد حركه الشباب
[موسيقى]
شتاء دافئ تعيشه اوروبا بفضل نجاح النصائح
والحملات التوعويه من الحكومات والخبراء
الاوروبيين عموما وبالتالي نجاه القاره
العجوز من السيناريو الاسوا وهو ازمه
الطاقه في شتاء قارس وفقا لوصفه جورنا
الامريكيه عن خبراء طاقه الذين يقولون ان
الوعي حول كيفيه استخدام الاوروبيين
للطاقه ومقدار تكلفتها نجح بالفعل وان
الاستجابه كانت لافته للغايه بما فيها
استخدام امدادات بديله وحفظ الاستهلاك
ووفر انخفاض الطاقه مخصونا امنيا مؤقتا
لامدادات الغاز في اوروبا والتي ابتعدت عن
روسيا من لغاز اوكرانيا الى منتجين اخرين
وخاصه الولايات المتحده
وبالتالي انخفض الطلب على الغاز في
الاتحاد الاوروبي بنسبه 20% في الربع
الرابع مقارنه بالفتره نفسها من العام
الماضي وفقا لوكاله الطاقه الدوليه
[موسيقى]
تقرير لصحيفه ساندي تايمز البريطانيه
الاحتماليه اجراء مصالحه بين الامير هاري
والعائله الملكيه البريطانيه قبل تتويج
الملك تشارلز في مايو المقبل وذلك بعد نشر
مذكرات الامير هاري تحت عنوان البديل
ووفقا لمصدر مقرب من الامير والعائله
الملكيه فان المصالحه ممكنه وان كانت
تتطلب تجاوز عقبات عده
من باب المصالحه قد يعود الامير هاري الى
اروقه قصر باكينده لكنها قد تكون عاجله
قبل تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث مايو
المقبل وفقا لصحيفه ساندي تايمز
البريطانيه
مصادر مقربه من الملك تشارلز والامير هاري
ترى ان اجتماعا قد يعقد بينهما في حضور
وريث العرش الامير وليام خلال الاشهر
المقبله
رغبه حقيقيه لجلوس الشقيقين مع الملك
تشارلز في غرفه واحده
ومصالحه ممكنه لكن تقف في طريقها عقبات
حسب تقرير صنداي تايمز تتطلب المصالحه
الاعتراف باخطاء الماضي من قبل الجميع وهو
ما يحتاج الى مرونه قد يفتقدها هاري
الراغب في الحصول على اعتذار من العائله
الملكيه لزوجته الى جانب المساءله قبل
المصالحه
العقبه الثانيه تتمثل في نيران كتاب
البديل التي جعلت الامير وليام يحترق
داخليا حسب وصف المصدر المقرب من الجانبين
فهل يستطيع وريث العرش الحفاظ على هدوء
بعد تركومات الخلاف مع شقيقه هاري
غياب الثقه المتبادله يظل حاجزا ليس فقط
من اجل اتمام المصالحه ولكن من اجل الجلوس
اولا فبحسب المصادر ينبغي وجود افراد من
الاسره يثق فيهم هاري حتى لا يعتقد انه
يتعرض لكم من ما
عقبه نحو المصالحه يسعى القصر الى تذليلها
وملك يرغب في تهيئه اجواء طبيعيه خلال
مراسم التتويج في مايو المقبل وان لم تهدا
الاجواء فقد تتحول الى مصدر الهاء وتشتيت
وفقا لمقربين من العائله الملكيه
علي السمان العربيه
مشاهدينا ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
[تصفيق]
سباق وتسلحين بين روسيا والغرب في
اوكرانيا
وبريطانيا بالدبابات ونيته يعدوا باسلحه
ثقيله
بشراء المقاتلات والذخائر الخاصه اسرائيل
تواصل التجهيز لضربه عسكريه محتمله ضد
منشات ايران النوويه
جمهوريه اسلاميه الى ايران
وبالاسعار العالميه